this last weekend I was in the restroom  and the girl in the stall next to me was  like hey do you have a tampon and I  froze I was like  sorry no  that moment I decided you know what I'm  always gonna have one on hand now I  confess that I have  um no personal first-hand knowledge of  what goes on inside a woman's bathroom  because I'm a man just like this guy all  that to say if I had to guess  I would suspect that a woman shouting to  a stranger in the next stall asking for  a tampon  is not a normal occurrence you can't  spare three squares no I don't have a  square to spare he expected that women  his fellow women as he considers them  would fall over themselves to thank and  congratulate him for volunteering to be  a tampon repository but instead actual  women just found the whole thing very  creepy and gross this woman just didn't  get it she kept harassing me